all right so thank you all for being
here
I'm Rashad I'm a product manager at dado
and today we're going to talk about
deploying scikit-learn models in
production so I should first tell you a
little bit about dado
even though most of you just sat through
like a 20 minute presentation about data
so I'll just leave you with the high
level overview dado provides a machine
learning platform for building
intelligent applications and intelligent
applications or applications that use
machine learning we offer tools to plot
to do data engineering data intelligence
and deployment so these are the the
three tenants of building an intelligent
application today so we want you to
build deploy and manage your intelligent
apps with data so that's it that's all
I've got for the company now I want to
switch gears and talk about deploying
scikit-learn models to production I'd
love it if you guys interrupt me with
questions or raise your hands with
questions let me know if I'm going too
fast too slow anything like that so if
we think about going to production let's
back up and actually think about how all
of us got started with ml and I can
certainly speak for myself my
backgrounds not in machine learning it's
in large-scale systems so I'm new to ml
so I'm learning data science like I like
I imagine many of you are so how
everybody starts with ml is pretty
simple you get some data it's pretty
universal
you learn about an ml algorithm and then
you learn how to apply that or an ml
technique on the data and you generate a
plot so sound right does everyone sort
of remember this is how they got into
machine learning
no nods oh I got I got nose interesting
okay
maybe you'll agree with me as I keep
going though so the idea is to learn
about machine learning so you want to
use the visualization to help you
understand the concept so the task that
you're doing is you're running a set of
experiments as you're learning a new
technique and the plots are the results
this is how you know whether you've
learned the the technique correctly or
whether you've applied it correctly but
this doesn't tell you anything about how
to deploy doesn't tell you how you would
take this model and do something with it
in a production setting so you don't
know how to get this model that you've
trained to be consumed by others and
this is sort of where the the training
in machine learning typically stops and
I think this is why you don't see a lot
of machine learning models directly
deployed into production settings it's
because it's not really part of learning
machine learning to learn how to deploy
machine learning so what ends up
happening if this is the state of the
world today so after working with a lot
of customers I hear this over and over
again so you still have data you still
have the ML algorithm but then this is
what the data scientists so this is what
you've built or what I've built as I'm
learning to be a data scientist but
unfortunately this is not what's
deployed
what's deployed is a totally different
model that's been implemented by a
different team
maybe data engineers or software
engineers and so the output of the
machine learning exercise is a
specification for another team to
implement in a production language it's
this this is hugely not optimal this is
a this is not a good situation for a lot
of reasons so for one it takes a long
time to translate from one system to
another oftentimes you're
oversimplifying so the model does
certain things a certain way now you're
trying to implement that in a different
set of tools and it's different skill
set of people that are trying to do that
so you're simplifying the model to
explain it unfortunately if it takes six
months which I've heard directly from
customers more than once the state of
the world is uh has changed in six
months so what you've built is probably
irrelevant and then worst of all even if
you've gone through this exercise once
and now you're working on the six month
pace of having any iterative changes to
your model you've got two systems and
two teams and now your situation is even
more fragile so if this is what we're up
against today why are we in this place
why is it that the machine learning
model can't
be deployed what's preventing it from
being deployed today what's holding it
back
what's holding back the scikit-learn
model so first from my the way I see it
machine learning models are very opaque
objects they're stateful they're not
easy to interact with it's not easy to
know how you integrate a trained model
into another system so I tried to
represent this with this graphic you've
got some data it goes into an algorithm
which I love this depiction which
somehow seems math mystical and magical
and what you've learned is a function
what a function doesn't seem all that
accessible to use directly so there's a
lot of effort into trying to export your
trained model using a markup language
but unfortunately a lot of models don't
export and so that that makes that makes
it tough and then really I believe that
since the goal of a lot of the machine
learning libraries is to help you get
through conduct experiments quickly the
focus is on how quickly can you train
the model not necessarily on how quickly
can you generate predictions from the
model does that sort of make sense so I
see this is the the challenges that
exist in the current system so what I
want to spend some time on now is
brainstorming with you guys and going
through a design of how we would build
the system that would allow us to handle
live production traffic and have it
directly served from our trained machine
learning model so this is our goal this
is what we this is the system we want to
build so if we were starting from the
beginning how would we design such a
system so we're switching switching
context from what a data scientist does
to let's build the architecture let's
design the system architecture for this
so if we're gonna build a new
architecture we should start by looking
at some reference architectures and and
get inspired by them so if we look at a
multi-tiered architecture from the
internet today you'll see that it has
some interesting properties client
machines go through the big bad internet
and hit a load balancer which then
siphons off traffic between a set of web
servers and those web servers are they
allow you to scale horizontally you can
keep adding them as your load goes up
and then those web servers have some
sort of this thinks that sharing session
but you can think of this as a database
or a storage layer that's shared between
them so you have this this application
serving layer that's horizontally
scalable and then your storage layer is
by definition typically less scalable do
you guys agree with this architecture
that this is pretty common in the web
today ok so our goal is let's generate
requirements and the technical product
manager in the back of the room is
should be happy about this we're
generating requirements if we wanted to
build this same architecture but for ML
models how would we go about it what are
the requirements that are important for
building this type of system so the
first requirement is pretty
straightforward whatever system we build
it has to be easy to integrate with so
how do you do that let's put a
service-oriented architecture in front
of it let's make it have REST API so
that makes sense so if you look at the
architecture diagram you've got now got
a web serving layer this is I'm
representing it as an API which this is
what your users or applications are
interacting with directly this makes
sense this part of the architecture
diagram now if you have a REST API you
should have the ability to query this
API from a lot of different languages it
shouldn't you shouldn't be locked into
whatever technology you use to build the
this REST API so this way you don't
you're not locked into Python from the
client-side if you've built this API
layer in Python and if you look at some
pseudo code maybe this is how you would
interact with it in Python you'd you'd
want to connect using some URL and some
authentication key and then you'd want
to be able to query by passing in a URI
or a service name which is the endpoint
you want a query and then the data that
you want to pass to that that the input
to that query this sort of makes sense
what we're doing here we're going
through a set of requirements for
building this type of architecture so
we've gone through one it's got to be
easy to integrate
the second one is pretty obvious it's
got to be high performance or for low
latency remember our goal is live
production traffic so first and foremost
let's put a load balancer in that's a
great piece from our sort of our
reference architecture that we looked at
so so now we've added to this to the
system architecture diagram where
there's a load balancer and you guys can
see the mouse yeah okay so there's a
load balancer which is now pointing to
the set of API machines and then let's
add a distributed caching layer this
also makes sense like in many database
applications or database workloads the
database becomes sort of a bottleneck so
you want to introduce a caching layer in
front of the database so common queries
aren't aren't adding load to your
database so I think that that
architecture makes sense for this space
as well for machine learning models and
this last piece of the picture I've
called it the engine now this is the the
component that's actually hosting the
model so we have a distributed cache and
I should clarify what I mean by
distributed cache a distributed cache it
means that there's a piece of the cache
running on each node of this cluster but
they're they all work together so
there's one caching namespace so when
you're looking for something in the
cache the that item may not physically
live on that same machine but it's
abstracted away from the client or the
guy using the cache in which in this
case it would be the API server does
this sort of makes sense when I'm saying
what what I mean by a distributed cache
yeah so oh and I've got pseudocode so in
this case I'm trying to do something
administrative so I should have some way
to administrative Lea send an admin sort
of command
so maybe again I'm using a URL to
connect to the cluster and I'm using an
administrative key and in this example
maybe I'm just enabling the cache
because it was disabled and I'm turning
it on so we've got two requirements this
is not sufficient what we have this
picture is not sufficient for meeting
our goals so what's the next one well
the next one that seems pretty obvious
to me is we have to be fault-tolerant
and so let's get that model running on
all the machines so this is a difference
than a lot of the database architecture
that I talked about before where for
many relational databases they are
single node machine they're single node
products they're single machine products
and so you can't do this
but for if we're designing the system
and we're generating requirements for it
the ideal situation would be to put that
model on every machine now if a machine
goes down your system still operational
so what do you need if you have a fault
tolerant system well you've got to be
able to get status on the cluster and
you've got to be able to replace nodes
that might be impaired things like that
so I still don't think we're there now
that we've got this we've got and so I
think of each of these blue boxes as one
one machine whether that's a virtual
machine or a physical machine these are
components that are all living on the
same machine so in this example I have a
three node cluster with a load balancer
in front so we're not quite done with
our requirements because it's not good
enough to just have three nodes your
systems got to be scalable you've got to
be able to go to four nodes or five
nodes or eight nodes so you have to be
able to elastically scale the cluster up
and down this totally makes sense it's
the same reason from the the reference
architecture and that we looked at
before that based on demand based on the
operational characteristics of your of
your cluster if you want lower latencies
let's add more nodes or you could look
at the the surge queue on the load
balancer there's a lot of fun ways to
find em I as my system overloaded
latency is an obvious measure but
there's a bunch of others well now that
you've got a scalable system you've also
got to be able to configure it and that
means things like this distributed cache
have to do the right thing when you add
a node so you've got a re partition keys
across the nodes you've got to make sure
that the the new nodes continue to use
the cache was that a question okay and
so uh pseudocode again simple command to
add some know
and an equally simple command to remove
a note so we're getting there I mean
these four requirements so far seemed
pretty good if we had all of this this
would this would be a pretty good system
but I still don't think we're there the
fifth one to me is that and this is
definitely for my engineering background
having to carry a pager for many years
the system has to be maintainable so
when you're doing deployments when
you're updating a model so if you go
back to the idea of what you want to
have when you have this type of system
you want it to handle live load but you
also want to deploy new models to it or
update existing models regularly say
every hour or every day or every week
depending on your application and you
want those deployments to be seamless so
zero downtime with rollbacks you need to
have metrics logging these are this is a
production system so it needs all of
these things that you'd use in operating
the system and we talked about model
management well you need that in this
case because you're deploying a bunch of
models to each of these clusters and so
now you want to know which version of
which model is deployed where how if you
need to rollback how do you go to the
previous version and and when was this
version deployed those types of things
become important you need to have that
that auditability because this is a
production system and you want to really
really be deliberate about making
changes to it so pseudocode for adding
and updating models might look like this
so you pass in a URI which sort of
represents that model and then you can
update that model using that same URI so
this could be how in pseudocode how we
would and define this requirement so
we're almost there but I think we we
have to be a little bit better than so
far we've only been talking about
deploying trained machine learning
models I think we've got to do more than
that
we've got to allow arbitrary Python
because the truth is and all of you data
scientists can can agree with me or tell
me if you disagree with me you don't
just write one trained model you're
usually building that using a set of
Python packages and you're often ensembl
together so an application is rarely
served by just one model it's usually a
handful of models that come together and
there's usually some business rules that
tie them together
so instead of having to maintain a whole
other system to just manage those
business rules and have that system
query into this cluster to find out
what's the answer from this model the
answer from this model the answer from
this model I'm going to tie them
together and then return that by making
this cluster be extendable by just
supporting Python you can then put that
logic and the ensemble of models into
this one deployment so what you see I've
done is I've replaced the engine
component with something I just called
Python so in pseudocode if i was to
define a service i should be able to
define it just as a Python function and
so this is a really trivial example but
I've defined a function called service
it has an input called data the I look
inside this this dictionary of data
looking for a field called user ID I
then check is this user ID new to my
system do I know this user ID if I do
then for this application maybe I
returned a fixed set of items maybe this
is a recommendation system and so I'm
going to return popular items to a user
I don't know but if I know this user
then I've computed my model has been
trained using this user's history so
then I'm going to return recommendations
for this user instead it's a really
simple example of how we've wrapped a
model inside a function and we can
deploy that as a service so what do you
guys think so far if we had this system
would we be there would this would this
get us to our goal of no more oh I
actually think we're pretty close so I'd
love to hear what if you guys think
there's more requirements there's more
okay
so to recap what we've covered so far
easy to integrate high-performance fault
tolerant scalable maintainable and
extensible so now that we've sort of
defined the what
what are the requirements we want let's
put on our engineering hats and think
about the how how would we go about
building this so we've defined the what
we did the why in the beginning now we
did the what now we're gonna do the how
so if we're gonna do this ourselves what
do we need well we need a web service
layer so if we're in the Python
ecosystem we could use tornado flask
I think it's Klein not keen I might have
gotten that wrong
Django pylons pyramid there's a bunch of
different application frameworks in
Python that can help you spin up
services so we pick one of those we'd
probably evaluate that run some
prototypes against them again the key
metric here is throughput I think
because you want something that can
handle live traffic well you need a
caching layer based on this architecture
that we talked about so you might use
Redis or cassandra memcache D if you
want to be old-school like me or you
might use one of these newfangled no
sequel databases like dynamo DB or
Berkeley DB or you could try and use a
relational database which also tries to
recently they've been there's been a lot
of documentation around how the
relational databases can do
non-relational things pretty well too so
maybe you even want to throw my sequel
into this but the key metric when you're
evaluating this caching layer is low
latency because the whole point of the
cache is it's got to be faster to get an
answer from the cache than it is to get
an answer from the engine okay so now
we've got two of the layers in the
picture covered so what do we do for
logs
well maybe we use log back or log stash
or a service like Splunk or log lea go
ahead elasticsearch yes for the caching
layer you mean or for the logs for logs
as well yep and there's a man that's
certainly not exhaustive there's a lot
more you could roll your own which is
always a fun option
well metrics you've got a bunch of
options as well maybe you want to
publish directly to AWS cloud watch
maybe you want Mixpanel maybe you want
liberado
there's a whole bunch of other metrics
providers out there that I'm forgetting
so there's even more components to this
than this there's we still haven't
talked about how do we get model
management how do we get the the right
API
what's the where the models stored so
what's the the storage layer involved in
this
because the model should be stored in
sort of one central place so that you
know that with checksumming and all the
stuff so that you know that's the same
model that got loaded on each node so
you can imagine that there's quite a bit
to do here so we could go through this
and we'd talk for another hour or we
could use data predictive services so we
took these exam goal the same goal that
I covered with you guys the why and the
what and we generated the same
requirements these same six requirements
that these were the requirements we had
to satisfy in building the data
predictive services product and so I'd
like to show it to you guys that sound
good all right
we're gonna do a demo so all right demo
is over here oh oh okay
oh boy you know what I want to switch my
display so that I'm not I don't have two
screens because then I can't see what
I'm typing and that's no good
arrangement mirror whoohoo
okay now let's get rid of some of these
toolbars
good enough can you guys all read this
or should I make it bigger it's okay
okay so this is an eye - notebook or a
Jupiter notebook and this demo I didn't
want to go through a whole machine
learning exercise so I thought I would
just take a tutorial from PyCon 2013 on
linear regression and adapt from it or
augment it and I think this what I like
about this example is it covers a linear
regression using housing data with this
really well understood data set that's
actually ships with scikit-learn and it
stops with a plot that's the end of the
sort of tutorial so I think that that's
a great place to pick up and say okay
now let's let's actually deploy this as
a service so I'm not going to go through
the the details of this but we're doing
house price prediction using this Boston
housing data set that's quite old and
you'll understand that when you see the
prices so like like everything else in
Python I'm importing I import
scikit-learn I look at my data set I've
got five hundred and six rows I want to
get some characteristics of the data set
so you can see there's a bunch of
columns they all mean different things
you can see where this data set came
from and and sort of the governance of
this data let's start by plotting you
know this is an important step in
exploring your data and getting getting
into it so let's build a histogram and
matplotlib and this is all coming
straight out of that out of that
tutorial you'll you can tell when it
gets to the stuff that that I wrote
because it doesn't have any explanation
it just has it commands so here's how
you know that this is a pretty old data
set the price is in thousands so 20,000
25,000 and you can see the number of
houses that fall into this histogram so
okay this is the distribution of prices
since this is a tutorial or this came
from a tutorial it has some exercises
which we're going to skip
because that's not that's not the fun
part for us the fun part is to actually
build a linear regression model so
that's what we're gonna do here
so from scikit-learn we we import linear
regression we're going to instantiate
the object will name it CLF and then
we're going to fit or train using our
data set so let's do that so now we have
a this model has now been trained and
because this is a from this tutorial the
next thing it did was make a plot after
generating some predictions so this we
called CLF da predict so now we
generated predictions for the same
training set and now let's plot that so
what you can see is the true price on
the bottom on the x-axis along with the
predicted price so how well did we fit
that line so this is basically where
most machine learning tutorials stop so
let's pick up right from there and say
we want to take this trained model and
deploy it as a service how would we do
that so first and foremost we'll define
our web service so this is that Python
function that takes whatever data we'd
like as input whatever inputs we'd like
and then calls predict on the trained
model remember we named it CLF that was
what the the variable was called and we
call predict passing in whatever was
passed in for data we get back the
prediction and then we want to take the
prediction and wrap it into a JSON
object to return it this makes sense as
a Python function yeah okay so now we've
got our serve we've got the function or
the service we want but we don't have
the cluster yet so let's build up that
cluster so now we're gonna import
GraphLab create so import GraphLab and
the reason i should bring this up just
to make it clear data predictive
services is a product that doesn't
require a graph lab create but graph lab
create has a client to connect
and let you launch predictive services
does this make sense you can launch
predictive services on their own but you
can also launch them from within
graphlab so I'm going to show that from
graph line I know that's a little
confusing and we're working on making
that better we want to have a separate
Python package that's just a connector
or client for predictive or predictive
services and data distributed but we're
not there yet so right now that client's
baked into graphlab create okay so all
of you that have worked with ec2 or with
AWS know that there's a bunch of
metadata you need to keep things like
your access key secret key what instance
type you want to launch what region you
want to launch things in and where where
you want to store your logs and s3 these
are things you don't have to type in
over and over again so we have this
convenience object that we call an
environment that defines this
configuration of this metadata so this
is the one that I have saved on my
system
you guys all now see my access key but
don't ask for my secret key because it's
secret and this is uh this is a named
object so this is something that's saved
away in my home directory so whenever I
use GraphLab create I can easily
retrieve it so the next step is
launching the service and so I'm not
going to show you that because we have
to then wait for ec2 to actually spin up
instances and that takes a bunch of time
and I don't have that many jokes and so
I can't kill that much time but I do
want to show you the API it's one
command we give a logical name to this
cluster to this deployment which is then
how we can refer to it we provide this
configuration oops cannot double-click
we we pass in the configuration the ec2
config we want to use and then we
specify where an s3 we want to keep all
the state information about this
deployment this is really important I
didn't cover this in the requirements
but you can't build a system for
production where all the stateful
information about the deployment is
sitting on your laptop because then if
your laptop gets run over you've now
lost your handle to your cluster so the
way we built predictive services all of
that stateful information is
stored in s3 if your cluster is being
deployed in AWS in one place that you
specify the reason that this is so this
not only helps you in the case of your
laptop getting run over but it also
helps you just a sec in the case of you
have you all of us work in teams so
oftentimes you're sharing deployments
this is how you email your your
teammates to say hey I've set up the
cluster here's how you connect to it to
deploy models to it so go ahead what was
the question the question was security
how do we maintain security really
important question
so with data predictive services the
infrastructure is yours meaning these
are your AWS credentials these instances
launch in your account Daito has no
access to them no absolutely not
that's right so the the okay so this is
a very important distinction so the
question was what happens to the keys do
we send the access key secret key
everywhere the answer's no we follow AWS
best practices what's happening is when
you launch this cluster your local
machine is making the AWS commands to
actually call ec2 run instance so that's
happening from your local machine so the
keys aren't going anywhere except does
that answer your question yes and AWS
helps you with that there's like an 800
number and there's a there's the whole
thing so this is at 10 minutes perfect
does that include questions or no total
oh okay
okay so I want to show you how to so
here I'm loading the predictive service
using that exact same using that state
path this path that I'm talking about
here so this is an existing cluster that
I have and I can show you what's you can
see what's deployed when I printed out
this the logical name for this is demo
lab psych it this is the API key which
I'd need to make any query requests
there's also an admin key which is what
I need in order to make administrative
changes like adding nodes removing nodes
the cache is enabled and this is the
load
balancers DNS name I also see what are
the services or predictive objects that
are deployed so right now I only have
one
it's called funny and it's at version 6
I have nothing pending so what are some
of the administrative operations I can
do I don't have time to go through all
of them but you can do you can change
your cache you can actually do more
fine-grained cache control how much RAM
do you want to devote to the cache on
each node what's the time to live for
all your cache keys per model and for
the overall system you can scale up and
down by adding and removing and you have
all the operational features like
getting the metrics if you want to get
them programmatically getting the status
where you get that back programmatically
as a JSON objects so you can then go and
and analyze it with code the logs are
periodically shipped to s3 like you
would you wouldn't want to take the the
i/o hit to try and write your logs in s3
all the time so you write them locally
and then sync them to s3 periodically
but if something's going wrong you don't
want to wait for that syncing to happen
so you want to be able to flush the logs
immediately and if a nodes going bad or
is no longer performing well you can you
want to just be able to replace it so
it's no longer impacting the overall
system so this is just a sampling of the
administrative things you can do using
predictive services so back to our task
at hand
which is taking this predict function
that we define the predict service and
deploying it to this deployment
so it's deployment dot add I'm giving it
a URI this becomes the rest endpoint and
now we're in production or we're dealing
with our production system so we don't
want things to happen incidentally so we
make it really explicit you need to call
apply changes for all the pending
changes to get applied and this is the
first time that the model that I had
trained in this ipython session running
on my laptop has left my machine so
what's happened is we've uploaded it to
s3 and then notified all three nodes in
the cluster that there's a new model I
need you to download it so you can get
to all this stuff programmatically
through our API we also offer it with
some visualization I'll zoom out a
little so you guys can see this a little
bit better whoa okay
oh I can't this is what the projector
can do so you can see that I've got the
the I now have two objects that are
deployed funny and this new one house
and you can see some operational metrics
being plotted and you can always link
away to all of cloud watch to set alarms
and all to set up your alarms and things
that you'd need to measure to operate
the service so that your pager can go
off at night and you can see this is a
three node cluster and each of the
instances are in service so now let's
query it and I'm running a little out of
time so I'll just go kind of quickly so
I want a query I'm going to use the
first row from my test set from my
training from my data and all this is is
a numeric value for each of those
columns or those features that that are
in the data set so that's my example I'm
going to use the Python client that's
baked into graphlab create query the
house service that we just deployed with
this example and what you see is I
connect it to the predictive services
load balancer and I got my response from
there the result is for this house given
the these features the predicted value
is $30,000 you also see a request ID for
debugging for end-to-end debugging so
this is your request ID for the request
and you know which version of the model
returned this response so this is
version 1 and that's it I can go back to
a couple slides to wrap up look that's
my email is that the one yes so see if
this works yes
so data predictive services lets you do
all the things we talked about and more
so I'm available for questions
oh yeah deploying a new version I'm
gonna go right back to the code here why
don't I see the window it's it's just
deployment update and the name of the
URI and then the model so just like we
did deployment dot add there's
deployment update other questions go
ahead absolutely yeah so meaning this is
why we queue them up right so you call
add add add update update update and now
if we look if I look at my deployment
you'll see that I have two deployed
models and I have a pending change to
this to this service and the new version
is version two so now when I saw all I
did there was I called update instead of
add so does that make sense so all the
models are cataloged which ones are
pending what version they're going to
get updated the next time you call apply
changes that's right each deployment can
have an arbitrary number of models it
really varies it depends on the
application and this sort of depends on
your overall network topology in your
organization some some organizations
really like having each application have
a siloed set of infrastructure that's
independent other other organizations
really like having a lot of shared
infrastructure so it depends on how your
organization likes to do things and it
also depends on the workload of the
models go ahead
users well there's kind of two ways to
do that I think the simplest I would you
could either ensemble it inside one
model so really one model is a
collection of 15 million models or you
could externalize it it depends on how
you want to Train actually I'll say this
way it depends on the velocity that it
with which you want to Train the
personalized models go ahead you Jane
yeah
right right so another way to say that
it's context-aware predictions so what
is your user interacted with on your
website what are the products they've
seen there's no point recommending those
products if you're looking for
recommended products as an example so
there's two over here and then I'll come
back go ahead yes and no so yes we are
pickling when we can but pickle is a
pretty fragile so we've wrapped we've
wrapped pickle with what we call GL
pickle but it's it's a same idea and
then we're then for this because we're
deploying to s3 because we're deploying
this this deployments on AWS we are
pushing that model to s3 and then
notifying all the nodes in the cluster
to pull the model from s3 there was
another question here yeah
that's a great example so great you can
do it with an annotation so it's from
GraphLab deploy import required packages
so required packages takes a list of
scikit-learn equals equals 0.16 dot 1 so
this is disutility lever we deploy this
service we'll make sure these required
packages are on them on the machine
that's correct yeah that's correct
there was another question here yeah
oh so you watched it it's just this one
API called that I didn't run only
because it takes ten minutes but it
really is just one API call to get the
cluster going and the only configuration
you need to give it is this ec2
configuration so we've tried we try not
to that you shouldn't have to so we've
done our job right with the tools you
have all the access you want the the the
challenge we face about giving SSH
access which is the question was SSH
access can I SSH to those instances once
they're launched and poke around the
reason we've been hesitant to do that is
for one it makes it tougher for us if
you start building tools expecting SSH
access and things to be where they where
they are in one version we can't go and
update that and make changes to it
without breaking those tools so that's
one of the reasons but if there's a
reason that I'd love to hear about
reasons you want to SSH or you feel you
need to because those are great
requirements for us we need to build
that tooling in zero minutes ok so one
more question here and then I'll stop
for reproducibility
some version of you absolutely we do so
in in the GraphLab create models you can
always provide a random seed now some of
the models are inherently random or
inherently probabilistic so even with a
random seed you reproducibility is
difficult so so it depends on the model
so as much as possible with GraphLab
create we offer reproducibility but some
of the models that people are what we
implement the model so but some of the
models are not you will see yeah okay
yep okay - one minute but go ahead
oh you that's oh it's a really good
point so if you look at this output here
and we went through it really fast but
you'll see that the version is in this
place where we where we uploaded - so
you can easily roll back or get to any
prior version and load that like load
that again it's not oh the function
itself is the function is pickled so you
can unpick alit yes oh absolutely you
can inspect see the source code the the
whole thing yeah yeah we capture all of
that we need to or else we won't be able
to run it on the other end okay
Thanks